it's the morning after in the land of
the World Cup champions
so German soccer fans there's no better
way to start the day
they're waking up to a dream come true
many had slept very little after
celebrating their team's victory not
much three hours for up at six four
hours three or four not at all
we partied all night so many partying
was more important than sleeping
millions of fans had been on the edges
of their seats for 113 minutes until
Mario götze shot the winning goal and
then there was no stopping the Germany
fans great we've won the World Cup 2014
stars four stars awesome Germany the
best team in the world the best team in
the world kept its fans in suspense for
a long time but in the end their
exceptional qualities gave them an
advantage over Argentina their defense
was excellent team spirit that did it
you mentioned a mine shaft one team I
thought it would be a clear win for
Germany but in fact we had to wait till
the very end
guts it was amazing hog the gun for the
whole team was outstanding it couldn't
have gone any better
mister me and thousands of others are
very happy so what can I say we won with
the world champions what what do you
want the party goes on throughout the
country as Germans celebrate this
unforgettable event
you